the big acm awards in nashville and that
is where our rachel smith is
in a very very famous spot hey rachel
yeah that's right kevin molly i
am at the historic bluebird cafe so many
country greats have performed here
even blake shelton and gwen stefani did
it virtually for the acms last year
and speaking of blake he's got some new
voice competition
thanks to new coach ariana grande but
the seven-time
champ isn't exactly shaking in his
cowboy boots
i'm excited about ariana joining the
show because it's somebody new for me to
beat
i mean i'm tired of beating john every
season
nick is the easiest coach i ever beat
looking for a challenge i think ariana's
she could be a challenge
[Music]
on sunday blake will take a break from
his quest to win
his eighth season of the voice taking
the stage at the acms to perform
two songs his buddy dirks bentley will
also be performing
singing a youtube cover with husband and
wife duo the warren treaty
they were the first african-american
married couple to perform
on the acm award so that's history i
think it's a really great song for right
now
with all that's going on in our country
[Music]
ashley mcbride will also be taking the
stage with her band
she's up for four awards including
female artist of the year
when i look at the thumbnails of the
women in that category and i see my face
next to those faces
i laugh because it almost seems it still
seems kind of unbelievable but
here we are
[Applause]
[Music]
and we've got much more with all the acm
performers and nominees tomorrow
including our blake shelton exclusive so
hopefully kevin molly he'll have a
little wedding update for us
oh rachel we know blake always has a lot
to say thanks so much